it feels a little early to get something  like this but my my god doesn't make  mistakes  chance the rapper won the Humanitarian  Award at Sunday night's BT Awards and  received an extra special treat former  First Lady Michelle Obama  surprised the rap star with a sweet  video message before he accepted the  honor chance you are an outstanding role  model and an inspiration to all of us  who care about our next generation  because of you countless young people  will grow up believing in themselves  fulfilling their god-given potential and  then reaching back and lifting up other  people along the way leave it's a chance  to deliver a stirring call to action  during his speech he received a standing  ovation I was going to tell those judges  that we just need a conviction when you  notice is wrong for doing this but my  big homie Reese told me that we got to  work on ourselves before we could work  on the world